hold on Renzi the coffee sip on you yeah
ready make it real weird
yeah just art slurping I just do the
same thing hi I'm Danny hi I'm a barista
and I've been a barista for about one
and a half years now hello I'm Kelsey
I'm also barista and I've been a furry
stuff for a little over three years hi
I'm Rachel and I'm a former barista for
seven years
hi my name is Mia net now I guess and
I'm a barista for one and a half years
what is your favorite fast food coffee
I think McDonald's is like pretty good
East Coasters would know what wah-wah is
what's your favorite that's a guy I
think jack-in-a-box the iced coffee it's
pretty good I gotta go with McDonald's
coughing because that's really it's just
the backbone of America I think you
could have given me every type before
and I'd still have no idea but I'm gonna
stay optimistic that I'm gonna be able
to get like a solid two I was gonna say
it's all to bring on the coffee oh oh
yes ma'am that is like a punch to the
teeth oh man every morning at 5:30 I'm
making these coffee so I'm like oh yeah
I don't know maybe I'm doubting now yeah
hold on isn't it it could be pie smells
like very medium yeah
I'm tasting the filter I am a tasting
mmm some sweat dirt straight dirt maybe
some quick fryer oil leftover the reason
why I think it's Starbucks is because
this is just a stronger blends it just
tastes like a more quality of a brand
yeah if it isn't Starbucks I'm gonna go
to this place I'm gonna give it a four a
four with personality one point two rude
but I respect it regrets the quality
like it's like a seven yeah it's like a
good coffee
I'll give it a seven and a half this is
God McDonald's I'm gonna go 7-eleven
yeah at Starbucks I think this Starbucks
[Music]
thank God
oh you can't run this wait it's not like
a very strong smell that you're getting
I'm in the first one for the Starbucks
when I definitely got a stronger smell
this is like pretty Donuts oh it's like
watery yeah I'm not into the wateriness
no it's also more acidic this one yeah
and we know how I feel about acidity we
don't like her she's not welcome it's
just like a stronger water it just
doesn't have like the bean flavor it
seems like it's like water down very
watered down so it's either like it's
not it just wasn't brought the right
thing or this is that light of a blend I
would rank this a 1 out of 10 don't do
it right this about a 2
yeah we're probably just like a 4 I'll
give you 30 I think it's gonna I think
it's I don't think it's Duncan I think
it's like Burger King I'm gonna say
McDonald's I don't think that's
McDonald's I think this is I think this
is Evan 11 really Wow that is either
burger here McDonald's but I thought
McDonald's have better hot coffee than
this it's hard the guy to smell really
it doesn't really
in this Dunkin Donuts after you have
this all works you just don't go back we
started - oh that one's a little sour
badness o spite this is this is strong
this is definitely a stronger coffee
that was brewed better um it does have
the same like lightness of it I think
I'm just gonna scale everything off cuz
I'm being far too hyper critical so
we're gonna move the four to six
McDonald's two at three and if this one
or two yeah I'll give us one at two I
would rate this top you like a sip it's
not bad it's just not personally I think
I might even give it a 7 really I'm
gonna go with the four Burger King I'm
gonna say Burger King - so I'm gonna say
I'm between Duncan and 7-eleven but I'm
gonna say this is Duncan I think it's 11
one of us will be right yeah nice
7-eleven see this to be fair never
actually got conference in eleventh when
a Slurpee is the option it's the option
[Music]
this one has a stronger smell for sure
ah yes water from Los Angeles tap it's a
little acidic that's not like a lot it's
mostly just water maybe like someone
just like forgot to like make a new pot
um again yeah lighter than I thought it
was gonna be there I'm gonna give it a
three out of ten I'm gonna give it to
what are you gonna do it I think I gave
a six I was gonna say sighs I think I'm
giving everything that number
my father is doctor doughnuts is this
Dunkin
I'm just gonna do the opposite of what
she said and I'm gonna say it's Burger
King we gotta get this one right we have
to be a oh I'm gonna say Burger King
because I believe Duncan could be better
it you know we did Burger King last time
ago fried I know it's coming down to the
end okay okay Burger King done it bad
it's lighter than what I remembered for
some reason I think over the years
coffees and I can these faster that's
one changes for sure
[Music]
so we already know it's Burger King but
we're still gonna like rank it I was
dozing toasted madam yes to the king of
the burgers this one this one I could
smell it smells a little smoky he does
like burnt yeah it's gonna wait to see
if it's actually burnt
oh no oh it's a no no I feel like I have
that like awful coffee breath
of like you know that person that like
whispers in your ear and you like smell
weird coffee like yes yeah that this is
so interesting who made this decision to
pick this on it's just a weird coffee
because it hits your mouth but then all
of a sudden there's like no taste to it
whatsoever
I don't feel anyone my path I don't go
anywhere that's the thing I mean you
don't feel it after it which I wonder if
they do that because they're so heavy
with food I'm gonna give this a 2 out of
10 it's like a four yeah water down
I don't know if I was really surprised
by anything I think a lot of them kinds
have made sense [ __ ] my first the second
answer I knew as McDonald's I was like
me I want to be too obvious but I think
I got one right I was supposed to get
stuff right it was maybe we were a
little harsh lot a lot of heart a lot of
hurt yeah I'm not better than these
coffees
no one is I'm definitely surprised I
thought they were all decent line
through the good it wasn't terrible I'll
take them off it's fast food coffee you
know you're there to get your caffeine
fix and all of them have that
you
[Music]